so we don't wish anyone ill really in
the television business such a volatile
business you don't ever want to root for
someone's firing but it's hard not to
notice that there's a lot of drama at
CNN first their top star in Prime Time
Chris Cuomo was fired not exactly why
then CNN plus blew up costing the
company hundreds of millions and then
Brian Stelzer got can if there was ever
a firing to celebrate it would have been
his but even we didn't celebrate and now
to wreck our day it looks like Mr Don
Lamont the source of endless
entertainment for us for many many years
is out he made the mistake of saying
that women over 50 are not in their
Prime oh yeah they can have babies too
so without even taking sides in that
debater being too literal about it the
bottom line is it looks like it's over
for Don Lemon he was not on the air
today which is bad if you're a TV host
here's how his co-host explain why he
wasn't there
President Biden makes a surprise visit
to Ukraine I'm Poppy Harlow in New York
here with Sarah seidner Caitlin Collins
is live in Warsaw Poland where the
president will be shortly Don has the
day off
I mean you know no offense to ladies on
the set but are we on let's be honest
are we gonna kind of Miss Don Lemon if
he's fired yeah a little bit Steve
krakauer has covered television for a
long time and really well and honestly
he's the author of uncovered he joins us
today hey Steve so what what's going on
and again we're not gloating in any way
but I know that you would know the
answer what's going on there it seems
like the place is like on the way to to
collapsing yeah you know Tucker I was a
colleague of Don Lemon as you say not
too long ago less than 10 years ago and
it seems like there's been you know you
know a real fundamental shift at the
network I mean it started you know only
three or four years after I left during
the Trump era I I think one of the the
biggest examples during the Trump era of
the media that really just just went off
the rails I write about it uh an entire
chapter on it not just my experience but
chapter of uh the experience of other
people that worked at the network and
and what happened there as well and now
you have Don you know Don was one of the
stars of that era of of CNN he was a big
Primetime host he's already been
relegated to the morning show now and
it's sort of this relic of the old
Administration that's being they're
trying to dig themselves out of you know
Don was was a big star he was like an
influencer and this this really is one
of the big problems of the media in
general right now you know Don kind of
bought his own hype and and and I I
think that when he made that comment
about Nikki Haley he thought he was
criticizing a republican he thought he
was criticizing someone you're allowed
to criticize when in reality he didn't
realize he's criticizing basically all
women and now all of his colleagues are
mad at him so so I think it's a big
problem with with digging themselves out
of this hole that they they brought
themselves into because of a lot of
factors that happen only a few years ago
during the Trump Administration
I mean Don Lemon is dumb and kind of
crazy but he's always been and that's
sort of the appeal so if you put someone
who's dumb and kind of crazy on TV you
expect him to say dumb and kind of crazy
things and like that's hilarious what
what was his crime exactly yeah I I do
wonder if in the olden days which again
we're talking about a few years ago back
whenever you know when when things were
going so much better for for Don Lemon
as you say this sort of thing might have
been swept under the rug you know I mean
still just Stack Up what he said about
Nikki helli with all the things he said
about Donald Trump or or other people in
that Administration I mean it's not even
close so but I do think that there's a
new mandate there and Don's sort of out
of favor right now because it's just not
really the direction of the network I
mean you know we saw during the Trump
era and we've seen since then a total
lack of introspection I get at this and
uncovered just about every story I mean
they make mistakes and they don't
apologize and then they and then it just
the trust in the media just keeps
getting lower and lower and obviously
CNN is trying to dig themselves out they
they need to improve their ratings it's
kind of in the tank right now Don is
kind of uh he might be a casualty of
that
yeah and Nikki Haley is a crazed neocon
and you're not allowed to criticize them
I've noticed so that may play a role too
Steve Packer great to see you tonight
thanks Tucker
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight